now justice is a word we rightly hear a
lot now when it comes to ukraine justice
for the victims of the atrocities being
discovered
bringing to justice those carrying out
alleged war crimes
videos of bodies in bush
accounts of the killing of civilians are
prompting huge efforts to gather
evidence and build cases that will
hopefully hold those responsible to
account but it is a hugely challenging
and no doubt hugely affecting task
in ukraine that task is led by the
country's prosecutor general
irina benedictova she joins me now
live
good morning miss benedictova
good morning thank you that you are
having me and i hope i've got the
pronunciation of your name correct um
everything's good it's it's russian
surname sorry
sagan
it's russian surname sorry i'm ukrainian
prosecutor general and i have such
complicated surname okay it's about
diversification it's a very funny thing
about when russians speak about
denuclearization
okay i understand how important that is
to you anytime and especially now so i'm
good this morning going to address you
as arena if you don't mind so i don't
get that wrong
um
what what can you tell us about the
situation that you are facing on the
ground in trying to
uh pursue and your task to build
evidence and so on
we have very brutal aggressive war
and actually what we see now in ukraine
it's still
fighting in eastern part of our country
absolutely brutal and aggressive
the nets region lugansk region
harke region are under attack this night
and actually we understand that russian
troops again and again started to
took our territory and started to take
sorry our territory and to kill our
people and we see this from day and day
you spoke with the chief of red cross
thank you very much for opportunity to
listen about cave region for this
morning we have actually number uh
only for this morning 1222
uh dead dead people in only in cave
region
uh of course what we see on the ground
in all regions of ukraine
it's
war crimes crimes against humanity
and we
do everything to fix it
would you regard uh knowing what we know
about what happened at the railway
station at kramatorsk
is that a war crime
absolutely it's a war crimes it was a
russian missile
which killed more than 50 people
these people just wanted to save their
life they wanted to be evacuated with
kids it was women it was children and
they just wanted to save their lives
it was you have
yes we have evidence we understand um
a lot of connections times and so on
that's why it will be one of other cases
in in our big profile you know that now
we started
5600 cases in ukraine only about war
crimes
um we have our anchor case from these
5600 cases uh oh two cases sorry
and we have our main anchor case where
we have
500 suspects it's a case about
aggression aggression crime aggression
russian federation against ukraine and
these 500 suspects it is the top
military stock politicians top
propaganda agents of russia federation
who do who have done everything to
started this war and they continue this
war in ukraine
does that 500 include vladimir putin
vladimir putin is a main war criminal uh
of 21st century or we understand it but
from other side
all of us um respect of international
law which is implemented in ukrainian
law
we know that three positions in national
jurisdictions have uh
functional immunity it is president
prime minister and ministry of foreign
affairs only this purpose because
they are still on their position they
are not suspects in our criminal case
but actually we understand when they
will not be on their
or if prosecutor of international
criminal court decided to prosecute them
they
will be responsible for all their crimes
so if i understand this correctly
as long as mr putin remains president of
the russian federation he has some
immunity but the moment
he loses or relinquishes office
he will be
vulnerable to prosecution by you
uh absolutely
international
practice has such examples that's why we
understand
we
started all
practice of tribunals so all
possibilities and cases in international
humanitarian law the practice of icj
um we see now very young practice of icc
that's why we understand different
strategies how to
punish
maine war criminals because actually
when
dictators do and do again and again do
the
aggressive very brutal worst in our
modern in civilized world it's not
normal it's uh we as the international
community should change maybe
instruments should change maybe
mechanisms and do everything not only
stop and punish we should to prevent
such
possibilities of
ordinary dictators
in the future
may i ask you you've talked about 5600
uh cases
can you tell us what the what is the
mechanism how first of all how do you
know about these cases and secondly then
how do you pursue them because we have a
history of course of war crimes taking
years even decades to be uh prosecuted
or and to bring people to justice
uh every every um
such case we have the facts
these five
5600 cases they're absolutely different
but by their size in one case it could
be only one factor of death civilians or
to destroy civilian infrastructure in
other cases it could be
actually 10 or 100 episodes as what we
see with our 500 suspects that's why
they're absolutely different by size but
it's impossible not to know about this
almost every region in ukraine
was bombed and we have a lot of
concrete facts in every uh region in
every city you mentioned with your
previous guest about mariuper case
more than
40 days uh city in blockade
we had a lot of
again facts about war crimes inside
mariupol we understand it's not only war
crimes it is crimes against humanity but
because now only in marijuana 90
percentage of civilian infrastructure is
destroyed we have other uh
cities in ukraine in northern part of
ukraine in eastern part in ukraine as a
for example hercule when russian troops
again and again bombed civilian objects
hospitals kindergartens
schools near 1 000 educational
institutions destroyed it is civilian
infrastructure without militaries inside
a city
it's not cities or it's town town
baradian
it's a
town
without uh militaries without military
infrastructure at all but it was bombed
and destroyed
thank you so much for
taking time out of your schedule i know
i know how busy you are but thank you so
much irina
thank you very much that you having us
here and we can possibility to speak
with your audience and i am very
appreciated for all great britain
citizens and especially
for your prime ministry who was
yesterday it's a really great support
for us and
you know we should stop it punish and
prevent if we don't do it now
you remember chichnya you remember
georgie you remember syria nothing now
ukraine what will be next nobody knows
that's why we should do it now very
professional
but to to do what we should to do
appreciate it
oh